Trinh quyền tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng trọng vừa công bố dự án vòng vang
kế hoạch phòng thu tên lửa tổng diet nhất kể tự thổi tổng thống luôn ăn rí gần
vòng vang được khi vòng sẽ bảo vệ nếu Mỹ trước mọi mỗi mỗi đezu át tự tên lửa đạo
tên lửa hàng trình vô khí xíu vật âm và cải hệ thống quan kích quy đạo
tuy nhiên giới chuyên giá cảnh báo dự án này đối mắt nhiều trở ngạn ký thuật và chifei
vừa đánh chặt tên lửa trong gia đoạn tháng tốc được có lý tưởng nhất
lại rất khó gió thời gian phản động của anh ăn
các phó an như dùng vệ tên trong bị tên lửa đánh chặt
khoảng vụ khi năng lửa giao đều yêu cầu trên khai hàng trăm vệ tên
và dế bị đối phương vô hiệu hóa khoảng vụ khi trong bị tên khoảng tình công mạng
mỗi ý tưởng của đàn được xem sinh lại đó là viên sỏi thống mình
tưởng được đề sốt quay thập niên một chiến tảm người
kế hoặc này trên khai hàng nghiên tên lửa đánh chặt cử nhỏ bài trên quy đạo
phản đốc độ bập và được chiến rắn bởi hệ thống k yến
để phát hiện tên lửa đối phương
tuyệt dự án bị vị và nămu ý chiến ở chiến mấy tư
nó có thể chở thành liên tạng cho bong vang hệ này
ngoài của mình phát đánh chặt trên khung rang
vong vang cũng được kì vong tích hợp những hệ thống hiện có như tế hát ạ đế
và triệu hại egis
để đánh chặt tên lửa trong vầy đạm dưới quy đạo và giải đận quay
ngoài những ý vấn kỹ thuật
những câu hỏi về hiệu quả tế
chỉ phía không lâu và phản ứng trí tròng lớc
cũng hiện tương lao của bong vang là giấu hỏi lớn